bon vous savez qu'on ne bouge pas par le
jingle ces panneaux sont en ébauche tard
bien et pensez à quoi là maintenant
présentement
mais je pense que le chauffeur de taxi
m'a dit quelque chose de drôle il m'a
dit qu'un brécey ces gosses quinté
arrive à la maison ce soir et chez nous
les gosses hélico alors
quand vous étiez petit milliards
semblait acquis je voulais te noir avec
comme nino ferrer c'est ce qui nous
énerve le plus chez vous en vous
supportez pas ma timidité senghor sy tsy
misy donc ça se voit alors un gros
timide
hausse timide
je crois dans vos poches là
quelques freins dans la popoche gauche
et
qu'est ce que je savais que j'avais
quelque chose ici j'ai des vitamines à
moi oui 6 3 vitamines la période est
vitale et
camembert
qu'avez-vous fait que nous ne sachions
pas
j'ai fait un spectacle à la dernière de
céline dion avait invité à faire un rap
avec elle et puis j'ai rapper avec ce
livre c'est la dernière son show qu'elle
a fait pour l'an 2000 sur une île en
2000 l'arrivée et puis je faisais un rap
je fermais mes yeux pour me concentrer
sur le texte je faisais des moules à
bien
s approcher
aulas elle tombe sur scène non la paix
vous avez mangé une certaine façon
préventive vous feriez quoi si vous
restez 24 heures à vivre je pense que
j'en mourrais à bonnes réponses je lui
réponds
bien quand avez vous pleuré pour la
dernière fois
sérieusement j'ai pleuré à paris cette
semaine pourquoi il ya deux jours mais
moche et ça c'est un fait il est où ce
nom mais
il
est maniaco-dépressif
a fait c'est parce que en examen à paris
ça va faire une petite rue mais j'avais
bien j'avais un album de brel ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas écouté puis
j'ai mis ça dans moi dans mon disque man
puis je marchais dans paris demandé il
fait la tournée de la chanson jeff wade
c'est terrible quand sa part un
manifestant paris vii bonne image qu'il
faisait beau piège
quelle est la dernière personne que vous
ayez envie de tuer à par célyne durand
non je suis pas violent bonjour moi du
tout non tant avec les bras que vous
avez vous pouvez voyez là non non non
non ça c'est juste soutiennent mon père
par un gros tatouages sur les bras une
espèce de coeur les classiques de
l'époque le coeur avec le dag par un oui
c'est beau serpent qui tombe au coeur
avec un dragon qui crache des flammes
sur une fermette qui brûlait keating
donc ici
encore il a à ma mère
et mon père il a coupé si
vous en voyez quoi en vous et si vous
aviez une baguette magique je n'en
changerai peut-être d'effectivement un
titeuf planté là dessus mais mon côté
timide et
il veut aller non mais t'as fait jamais
essayé de faire du spectacle parce que
souvent les timides il faut
une bonne thérapie s'est
vu tout de suite tu as bien depuis le
début d'émission est comme ça on au
tutorat
déjà
le péché qui vous tente le plus
ben moi j'aime
bien la gourmandise moi j'aime bien le
gâteau je suis timide
est ce que je sais
de quelle question aimeriez jouer car
elle pose
la prochaine des fans rousseau